the Joe Rogan experience yeah well I
think sometimes people need to hear it
from some of their like you you know or
someone like Jocko or you know the the
beautiful thing about these podcasts is
that you get to hear people's
perspective and a lot of them are
eye-opening you know they're they
literally could change the world because
they change the way you behave and you
interact with people when you listen to
it yeah and that podcast that you did
with Jocko when I was listening to me it
changed my whole day it changed like how
I was gonna look at my day I was you
know instead of like looking at my day
like up it's a normal day I was thinking
god damn I'm lucky ah damn I'm lucky and
goddamn imagine experiencing what you
and how old were you at the time I was
21 21 years old yeah and experiencing
what you experienced in that insane
firefight being locked down and I mean
how many guys did you wind up engaging
with I I don't know I you know I don't
know I mean everyone they I got an
opportunity with right and just you know
it was just uh you know I was so chaotic
I mean I still die look I think about
all the time obviously it's something I
could have never experienced I mean I
trained for war every single day when I
was in the Marine Corps I mean it was
what I was what my job was and I still
could have never imagined that day the
way it was or anything to turn out I
could have never pictured it I could
have never and and and I think every day
it goes by I think there's a reckoning
of it right the way that I've seen it
that day is not the way I see it today
and I think that comes with you know
just just sharpening and just your body
you know you change and you see
different things in perspective but yeah
I mean you know I I you know that day I
mean it's still I mean it still is just
you know just it's just there's so many
lessons that come from that day that
that you know I look at people
complaining about stuff here in America
and it's like you know I seen him one
day the best of humans the worst of
humans and everybody nobody thought they
were wrong and it's possible you know
it's just it's just one of those deals
of you know that that day was just
that's an important point what you just
said nobody thought they were wrong not
them not you yeah you know I I but and
it changed me that day like I walked in
there that day and I was the guy who was
cocky who would tell you you know I love
fighting you know I mean like I like I
just want to go fight like you know but
every fight I had before that it was
like you know I always had airplanes
sitting you know our helicopters sitting
sitting around I always had you know it
was like I'm gonna go in there and start
the fight and then I'm gonna call in all
this other this other stuff to win right
and that day it wasn't there and and and
literally I walked out of there and I
just think about all the time today I
just think about all the time of how
many generations just that day were
changed how many generations of of
people's lives were changed you know all
my teammates died so they'll never have
kids that generations stopped their
families forever exhume any lives were
changed that day by that that that piece
and guess what and everybody in America
had no clue it was going on like right
now there are US troops
somebody wondering if they're gonna be
able to come home and see their family
again that's reality whether you want to
ignore it or not like that's reality and
that was me September 8 2009 and it was
just uh she was a chaotic day it's
amazing how you could have thousands of
days in your life in one day changes the
way you look at everything
one day changes the way you look at
everything and you know in like the the
further I go on that I look at it
different you know I always talked about
the story of you know whenever this guy
came up behind me and I ended up I ended
up killing him with the rock and I
always remember just like I remember it
like I see it every night like I
remember like I just see his face and I
got just because there was a point there
was a point that I feel like that
anybody that
when they whether they're injured or
anything like they realize they're
defeated like they like it like yeah I
don't know I just think there's a point
when you look at somebody and they know
they're gonna die and I'll never forget
that and I you know now I look at it and
I see it and how we thanked it like this
guy is a son to somebody his mother and
father are gonna miss him this guy he
believes in his cause as much as I do he
doesn't believe he's wrong this guy this
guy he he could have had a wife or kids
that are never gonna see their father
again just like you know my dad might
have never seen me again if it was
switched and really I don't even know
that I don't hate him I don't even know
this guy we're just here at this place
right now because we were born in two
different countries were you out of
weapons were you out of ammo so my know
he came up and he started choking me my
shot him once before and he I was trying
to pick my buddy dolly my one of my
closest afghans dolly had been shot he
got killed he had been killed and I came
around this terrorist to get him and I
was on my knee and this guy came up
behind me and so he didn't have a weapon
either he was no he did he had a weapon
and I end up shooting him from the
ground and I thought he was dead when he
fell on the ground and I kind of moved
down and got down with Donnelly cuz we I
was still getting shot at from this
machine gun up on this hill and I was
trying to make myself small as I could
and this guy ends up coming up at
choking me like I thought he was I
thought he was dead and he ends up
choking me out he starts trying to choke
me out and eventually let up a little
bit and I end up getting around him and
I just got we were fighting back and
Forrest and I can remember all I was
thinking about was like don't let his
legs get on me like you know these guys
their legs or I mean they been crawling
up mountains their whole life and he was
up he was a pretty big dude and
I just remember getting on top of him
for honey I got on top of him and I was
rolling on top of him he didn't have all
the gear on I did and I end up I
remember getting on top of him like like
I was straddling him and I'm just
reaching up trying to grab for anything
I can I'm holding him and holding him
down with my throat with my my forearm
and I'm just grabbing anything I can and
finally I ended up grabbing a rock and I
just started beating this dude's face in
and I started beating and beating and
beating and I remember I remember just
like finally like after hitting him you
know I don't know three or four times
four five times whatever I remember him
like finally just kind of looking at me
like just it's it's like he's like just
I'm just looking him in the eyes like
obviously closer than me to you right
now and you just see all the you can
tell like he knows where this is going
and I always think about that you know
obviously I would kill him a million
times over again right he was the enemy
like I don't feel bad about that part of
it but I just think about like in that
moment if I can find a way to relate to
him in that moment a man I'm taking his
life we all in America can find a way to
connect with each other if we don't
connect with each other's because we
choose not to I don't care what your
differences are like don't like find a
reason of why we can get along not why
we should not get along right and and I
always think about that moment you know
of this guy and you know he obviously
ended up dying and and and it would it
showed me was is that no cause that you
have that's built on hate Will Survive I
didn't hate this guy didn't even know
him but I was willing to to take his
life
because of what I loved and that's what
that's what we have to build our lives
in our foundation on is not not being
angry and hating each other but because
we love the cause that we believe in so
much does that make sense
it does make sense I understand what
you're saying
[Applause]